who am i i don't know about you but
olaf's crises are getting a little too
real and relatable disney and pixar
continuously creating content out of
their hit movies is nothing new
we saw it happen with films like tangled
toy story and we've certainly seen it
happen with frozen
whether you're 5 25 or 95 i bet it's
impossible for you to count how many
times
you've listened to let it go on one hand
but their newest disney plus short film
once upon a snowman is a total game
changer they used their famous
characters to answer some burning
questions
fans have been asking since 2013. so in
this video we'll be uncovering all the
easter eggs plot explanations and
naked norwegians yup you heard that
right that this seven minute film has to
offer
we know olaf but we don't really know
olaf
he's a friendly snowman who likes hugs
and was created by elsa
quite frankly he's the comedic relief in
the frozen films and without josh gad
would probably be overlooked but olaf
becomes the main character of his newest
short film and we learn a little bit
more about where exactly he went after
elsa creates him during her
let it go manifesto long story short he
gets hit with elsa's cape during her
dramatic
the cold never bothered me anyway line
and is sent
rolling down a hill where we find out he
actually has no
idea who he is i'm having a bit of a
crisis of identity
and then what commences is what happened
to him in the 20 minutes that he's
missing
from the actual frozen film still in the
middle of a meltdown olaf discovers the
same exact
travel post and sauna wandering oakins
that anna and kristoff visit in the
first film
you can even faintly hear kristoff
singing his
[Music]
when he passes his hiding spot it's here
that it's revealed to us that olaf and
anna
technically meet before we originally
thought
kind of he dramatically gets smashed by
the door as she's on her way out to
confront her future fiance
it's definitely not her most elegant
moment
in the first frozen film we never really
get the answer as to what exactly
happened to anna's coronation dress
after her visit to the trading post is
it in her satchel did she give it away
but in once upon a snowman that plot
hole is
finally covered when olaf walks into
wandering oakins we see the store owner
hanging up her coronation dress
for sale we're going to assume she
traded it for the
much-needed winter gear and carrots
there's even a price tag on the dress
that reads 55 of something does anyone
know what that would convert to in
dollars
things get a little nude with this next
easter egg
thanks to our friendly neighborhood
snowman we get the history behind the
name of the trading post
wandering oakens do you know that if you
scramble up those letters it's an
anagram for naked norwegians
despite not knowing how to read olaf
lets the store owner know that his shop
name is actually
an anagram for naked norwegians
we gotta give credit to the
scriptwriters for this one it was
definitely a smart way to get the adults
laughing even for a second
who knew that olaf and anna's difference
in height would help the creators reveal
things that we wouldn't have caught in
the first film
and kudos to them for even thinking of
utilizing that when olaf approaches the
wandering oakens trading post we get a
glimpse at two stone structures that are
on either side of the entrance
they happen to have an uncanny
resemblance to the rock trolls that
raised kristoff
but because they were placed so low we
weren't able to see them from anna's
point of view in frozen one
those rock trolls are also making me
think that kristoff potentially has a
history with this place and maybe the
store owner being kind of rude to him
was because he's been in confrontation
with him before what do you think
a snowman being obsessed with summer is
weird no doubt about it
it's even an awkward concept for the
characters in the movie but once upon a
snowman show
just how an object made of ice and snow
became so obsessed with the heat it of
course happens in the trading post
olaf is on the hunt for a nose and while
he later settles on a summer sausage he
first tries on
a stereoscope the stereoscope is full of
pictures of
summer that get his pupils dilating and
excitement building
speaking of those summer pictures disney
being you know disney couldn't resist
adding a piece of some other hit
movies in the short the pictures of
summer olaf seas
show some familiar sunny places that
exist in moana
and tangled did disney just give their
fans confirmation that all three of
these movies happen in the same universe
it
would explain why fans think that
rapunzel and flynn can be seen
entering the castle for elsa's
coronation
the pictures of summer also foreshadowed
just how olaf's future
in summer jazz number would look or more
specifically
where it would take place there were
cards that featured the field of
dandelions he pranced around
in the beach setup he also imagined
himself in and
even the gazebo that gave off major
sound of music vibes
it makes the fact that a snowman who
claimed to know nothing but knew a whole
lot about summer
makes sense there was also a summer
picture that included a specific red
checkered blanket
if you've watched both frozen films you
might find it a tad familiar
that's because it's popped up multiple
times it's in the summer postcard
reappears in olaf's in summer and then
makes a final appearance in the opening
scene of
some things never change in frozen two
what other way is there to bond disney
characters than
sending them into a wolf chase am i
right in the short we get another point
of view on the wolf chase that anna and
kristoff get themselves involved in
it was actually all olaf's fault he was
the one originally being chased after
the wolves caught the scent of his
summer sausage nose
he of course gets away by cleverly
maneuvering his body into a sled and
even legs but when he crosses paths with
anna and kristoff's sleigh the wolves
are thrown off course and start chasing
them it's interesting to see just how
the creators were able to fit olaf into
a scene that already seemed
so solid of course there would be
no way to end a children's short without
resolving the issue at hand
who am i and the way olaf discovers his
origins is
quite on brand he may have escaped the
wolf pack but one managed to escape
along with him
and olaf being the kind and selfless
character he is
sacrifices his nose up as a meal for the
hungry wolf
in exchange he gets ambushed by kisses
by the wolf
and is reminded of the warm hugs he
loves so much
elsa's discovery that water has memory
may have seemed random in frozen two
because of how
absent the concept was in the first film
but the creators made sure to bring it
back
in once upon a snowman
olaf can hear anna and elsa's childhood
voices from before he was even
created and how can he do this because
he's made up of
water and of course we now know that
water has
memory before the credits roll we see
olaf
walking towards anna kristoff and sven
to the scene that
would be their first meeting in the
first frozen film
disney did a great job of seamlessly
adding it all together to give their
fans another point of view of those 20
minutes in the film
not to mention a big glimpse at how one
of their biggest characters came to be
fans even get a little more insight into
why olaf acts the way he does in his
first scene of frozen
he's over the moon when anna literally
impales him with the carrot
and is quite satisfied with what he
thinks is a super tiny nose
it's all because he spent the last 20
minutes having
no nose hunting for a nose and then
losing his nose
this last tidbit isn't exactly a sneak
peek and may not answer one of your
burning frozen questions
but it is smart filmmaking on disney's
part in the middle of the movie olaf
asks himself i'd follow you apart this
is
well he answers his own question after
the credits when he
zooms across the traditional disney
castle and shouts
skill conclusion could disney have
finally found a way to make their short
films actually be something more than a
money grabber maybe they should consider
using these reels to tie up any loose
ends their films might have
think about all the minds they would be
putting to rest by giving their fans
all these answers and tidbits what do
you think was once upon a snowman meant
to be
just a way to bank off of the franchise
or did it put the fire out on some of
your burning questions
let us know in the comments below don't
forget to hit that subscribe button to
keep up with all things
the things